right that's 9 o'clock oh and the doors
quietly swing closed morning do we all
have our coffee can someone go get me
one ah good morning um for those of you
that didn't come to my talk yesterday I
hate you but that's fine
my name is Barry d'harans I am the
Dalton that security PM plus a bunch of
other ancillary things I just can't get
rid of which means I tell everybody how
to do things correctly and when they
screw it up I have to deal with it you
can follow me on Twitter as a blow dart
it's very sweary I warn you now but this
is Australia so that's fine because
swearing is a cultural thing the
Americans on the other hand they get a
little bit upset so today I'm gonna go
through nsrc bulletins nsrc being the
Microsoft security research slash
Response Center and what caused them
what we did wrong to cause the
vulnerabilities and things that you
might be doing wrong in your code that
will cause the same sorts of things then
a bonus advisory I'm going to talk about
how to encrypt properly and a few things
that we caught before they cause the
bulletin that some of you have probably
done in your own code so the way the
vulnerability process works if everyone
is being well-behaved is an email goes
to secure at Microsoft comm with details
of the problem and preferably a sample
that demonstrates the problem nsrc open
a case and put it in a dynamic system
which is really hard to use and they
route it to the product group they think
are responsible so for dotnet that means
I get an email in my inbox and I look at
the report and I try to reproduce the
problem and if I reproduce the problem
I'm like ok well this seems this seems
reasonable and then I go to a bunch of
VMs and I try and reproduce it again and
all the supported versions of our
product so that's don't 93.5 done that
four point seven even done that 2.0 in
certain circumstances all the versions
of core
and that takes a little while and
sometimes it only appears in certain
cultures or languages we've had one bug
report that only appears when your
culture is set to Thai so for all the
supported languages sometimes I will go
through a bunch of various different
ones so as you can imagine the test
metrics where this is really loud loud
large loud is me swearing and once we
were sure that we know that the problem
exists and has been reproduced I go find
the developers responsible for that area
of code and say look here is your
problem go away and fix it the fix
generally takes maybe a week a week and
a half for super complicated stuff the
fix can take a couple of months and then
we test the fix against all support your
help rating systems and all supported
software configurations plus a bunch of
third-party software that we have that
we know you should stop that in really
really horrible ways to try and make
sure that we don't break things and that
test process can take anything from one
to six weeks then I write the Security
Bulletin the fix gets pushed out
internally to a bunch of random machines
within Microsoft to make sure that we
don't break anyone and eventually on a
Patch Tuesday there will be a drop of a
fix so the important thing to know here
is really developing the fix itself only
takes one or two weeks it's all the
compatibility testing that we do and we
still get wrong every now and again it's
what sucks up the the large amount of
time I know some of you will believe
that we don't test our fixes at all I
assure you that we do so I'm gonna go
through all of these we need to talk
about hash dosage padding articles
sharepoint exchange with a little bit of
a sideways into docker regular
expressions cross-site scripting
cross-site request forgery russian
nation-state malware and then just
getting things entirely wrong by
believing what a user says none of these
are in any particular order they're just
in the order of the imine
to write demos to demonstrate them with
so a hash denial-of-service how many of
you saw this talk last year oh good I
can like treat this as a brand new
audience and do my cat thing denial of
service that was caused by parsing form
inputs from form submissions in asp.net
when we take a form submission or we
even take any HTTP requests to be honest
we shove a bunch of things in dictionary
objects in the dictionary objects are
backed by hash tables and if anyone who
has ever interviewed with a software
company where the interviewer wants to
prove they know more than the
interviewee you've had to implement a
hash table on a whiteboard so the way
hash tables work is it's just a way of
speeding up lookups in a dictionary so
I'm gonna explain this in terms of cats
because I don't like cats because I am a
dog person
cats are evil dogs are just full of
infinite love say you go on a holiday
and you own a cat because you're a
horrible person I'll let's be fair cats
on you not you own any cat and you have
to put your cat in a cat boarding house
until you take your cat - the cat
boarding house and say here is my cat
please look after him obviously the cat
boarding house wants to remember who
your cat is so when you can come back
again you get the right cat back so they
have this filing system they have like
26 rooms room a room B room C room D and
they take the name of your cat and they
look at the first letter and if your
cat's first name begins with a he goes
into room a she cats first name is B he
goes into room B so they're speeding up
the look at for what they look up for
when they have to retrieve the cat
because they are going to know which
room they have to go to and then they
look through all the individual cats to
look for the individual one that they
have to pull out and that's basically
how a hash table works try that and your
whiteboard next time you're interviewing
you'll get really strange looks
so obviously the more cats beginning
with a that there are the longer it is
going to be to retrieve your cat so if I
want to denial-of-service the cat hotel
I turn up with a thousand cats and say
they're all named Allan and all of the
Allens go into room a and there's
probably not enough cat cages or scratch
poles or wherever cats live in so you
are it takes a long time to take those
1000 cats and put them into the right
slot and then you come back again and
say okay I'd like Allan back and then
someone has to go into room a get
scratched because it's full of a
thousand cats and pick up each
individual one and bring it back and go
is this Allan you go No
this Allan you don't know and it takes
an awfully long time
there is your denial of service as
demonstrated by cats so the more you
force everything into their single slot
there's gonna be more and more cpu time
which leads to a denial of service so
this was presented in 2011 at the Chaos
Communication Congress which is a really
fun conference where they don't warn you
of all the things that are gonna happen
thanks guys so it can spoil your
Christmas it was originally targeted
against PHP Java Python and JavaScript
pretty much all of these vulnerabilities
are general they don't affect just
dotnet they will affect Java they will
affect Ruby they will affect Perl it's
just I know dotnet and I have to deal
with dotnet therefore these were all my
demos are written so we'll have a little
demonstration here if I go to where's my
hash DOS there is
it's a startup project the way we
implement hash tables in dotnet or for
dictionaries and dictionaries of strings
is we use the hash code that the object
generates how many of you have
implemented your own get hash code in
any of your classes yeah you're gonna be
nervous now so what I'm gonna do is I am
going to take a string and I'm going to
shove it into a dictionary and then I'm
going to take a really really dumb
string where the hash code is exactly
the same and I'm gonna put it in the
same dictionary and we will see what
happens so if I hit start it will
eventually compile okay so there's the
good hash code I put 1 million string
objects into the dictionary and the bad
hash code where everybody's hash is
exactly the same value is going to take
a demonstrably long amount of time to do
in fact if I leave this running
certainly in my old machine it would
never finish by the time that my
presentation had finished so I'm gonna
control see how is this so we have just
basically forced all our strings to be
called Alan by overriding Kokoschka so
we fix this
we fix this by actually randomizing what
string get hash code does so from one
instance of an application to the next
string dog hash code when it's shoved
into dictionaries we'll use a seed value
that randomizes it so you can no longer
say all my cats are named Allen and you
can also fake this by not using user
input class that you have constructed
from user input solely as a key in your
dictionary for those of you that have
implemented get hash code if you are
putting these classes as a key in a
dictionary and those classes are solely
constructed from user input you now have
a problem so what you end up doing is
having a static value in your class that
is a random value and you feed that in
as part of your hash code calculations
so from run run to the next it is
different we always said in the
documentation that hash code may not be
the same every single time you compute
it
it wasn't guaranteed to be the same from
one program execution to the next but of
course none of you read the
documentation did you we have people
that have saved get cash code in
databases and frankly it sucked to be
them we had a switch where you could
turn it off so and done that framework
you can turn that off or you can turn it
on and telnet core you have no choice we
are randomizing the hell out of you
because we thought net core we could
throw away some of the bad security
practices and implement the good stuff
next a padding Oracle attack Oracle's in
this case are not the database it's
basically just something that sits there
and tells the attacker something about
what they are attacking generally there
and called an Oracle because they don't
give them useful information they just
give them hints like the Delfy of Oracle
in Greece and whoever discovered this
first wanted to prove that he had a
classical education therefore their
Oracle's so and it hit speed up net
we had an endpoint which validated if a
string was encrypted correctly and we
would basically say yes this is good or
we would throw an error and that error
is enough of an Oracle to allow an
attack to happen because the time taken
to build the error and return it was
viewable enough over the Internet for
someone to build up an attack so the way
padding Oracle works is when you are
using padding encryption your data gets
split up into little blocks and the
result of the first encryption of the
first block gets fed into the second
encryption block and so on and so forth
and then at the end if your data is not
the exact size to be split into blocks
it gets padded it-- and this padding is
what ends up getting attacked so you can
tweak one bit in the last byte of your
encrypted information and send it to a
system and if the system errors and you
can measure that error you know that you
have tweaked that bit incorrectly so you
tweak it again and you work through
backwards byte by byte by byte by byte
until you get a properly encrypted value
so what the attacker could do in this
case was put in a file name the file
name being web.config and they could
just tweak each individual bit until
they got the right encrypted value for
web.config to push into this subsystem
without ever knowing the encryption key
the encryption key never leaked and
that's what we were doing in script
resourced or axd unfortunately once
you've managed to get web.config in
their script resource ax D was supposed
to do was to supposed to serve up
embedded JavaScript from resource files
in your application it wasn't just
limited to JavaScript files it would do
any file name that you give it so as
soon as the attacker sends web.config
web config gets served back to you and
web config at that point in time
included the encryption keys in it
which is a bit of a problem because now
I have the encryption keys that we are
using to create authentication cookies
so I have the encryption key for
authentication cookies I can create an
authentication cookie I can be anyone
that you want to be so we fix this we
fix this by making sure that script
resourced ixd only served up javascript
files in embedded resources and nothing
else and we also fixed it by making sure
that we're validated signatures the way
to stop padding Oracle attacks is not to
change your encryption but to make sure
that you have an authenticated signature
on the encrypted data and so you
validate the signature first before you
start trying to decrypt the encrypted
data and if the signature validation
fails you just say no and the difference
being there doesn't matter because you
can't fake the signature through any of
these techniques so it used to be that
we had a bunch of functions in dotnet
where you could encrypt or sign or
encrypt and sign when you are doing
encryption you should be doing encrypt
and sign or just cite if you don't need
the data encrypted you should never just
do encrypt always encrypt insane we have
a huge white paper on this that's in the
docs repo that no one ever reads so I
have a demo for this that sometimes
works because it's very dependent on
timing what else is running on my
machine and the internet speed and as
you're all aware the internet speed in
Australia is awful
so here I have a server that is going to
accept messages that are encrypted and
here we have the attack and sometimes
this works and sometimes it doesn't
really Jeremy uh all right you know what
let's just do that
well you must be he's made it right okay
all right you know we'll have to do it
with small funds now where does this
live CD one drive documents conference
presentations
oh there we go okay so sometimes this
works sometimes it doesn't like I say
it's ready to pay it's very dependent so
it's working backwards and because it
was written by an American they want
some very American things and there are
various ways to speed this sort of
attack up as you can see it's got stuck
there eventually it'll just either die
and I restart it and it might get a
little bit further along oh there we go
so what it's doing is it's it's it's
looking it's tweaking each individual
bit and trying to work its way backwards
and because we know that the message is
text we can sort of speed things up by
doing textual analysis and trying
certain values first you know eh-eh-eh I
you first because they're way up higher
in frequencies and then we can look at
what might follow after that and so we
can speed all these things up but
eventually Americans they like their
Declaration of Independence plus the
developer that wrote this for me thought
it'd be really funny
but we have you know we this is attacked
it didn't know what the encrypted stuff
wasn't it would just keep sending it
back and manipulating it until it gets
everything decrypted without knowing the
encryption key ever and this happens a
lot it's becoming more and more frequent
it used to be that you could just do it
with errors coming back from a padding
Oracle but the server in this case is
protected against padding Oracle's it
just it will just always return the same
thing but for languages that are
exception bist one that they throw
exceptions even if they're never exposed
to the end-user you catch them it takes
a little while to build the stacktrace
and everything else that gets bundled
into an exception and that's small
amount of time in which is generally
under a millisecond is still detectable
by people are fast enough networks which
of course rules out the attack coming
from Australia but if an attacker gets
hosted in the same data center as
a your cloud application there within
the same network I mean they may be
isolated a bit so it goes out and it
comes back in again but it's a short
enough hop that being stuck on American
Australian internet speed it doesn't
matter you're doing it all in the cloud
so these attacks are going to become
more and more popular and as I say this
sort of thing now is a problem for every
single language that uses exceptions to
cope with errors what we have been
sitting on this we sat on this until
last year because we wrote a bunch of
documentation and then we went to Google
and we went to his son owns Oracle now
our son owns Java or is the Oracle
whoever owned Java and we went to the
Ruby people we said look we have this
problem your library's your best class
libraries had exactly the same problem
with their encryption primitives here's
what we're going to publish you may want
to consider publishing your own I don't
know if any of them ever did we give
them a year and after that I'm like I
don't want to sit in this anymore so
this is a good reason for not using
encryption primitives
remote code execution a way of sending
something that executes on a remote
server this is a simple example that
actually is quite done that specific so
how many of you have used web forms
sorry you will be well aware that then
that web forms have this hidden form
field called view state and few steer is
as some people will say it's base64
encrypted
now it's base64 encoded it can be
encrypted but that that's an entirely
different thing and by default view
state is signing so someone tampers with
it it gets rejected and that's the
reason why you set the machine key in
web config and then have the same web
config in multiple machines so they all
have the same encryption key so you can
low bounce and send things about and
then of course then when you have a
padding Oracle your encryption key gets
leaked so sharepoint decided that this
was a bad thing because it was very hard
for people to configure cheese in web
config so they turned off the signing of
view snip which means you could send
anything you wanted in views there and
sharepoint would go okay now if you say
generally is is fill full of things like
oh here's what was gonna be pasted in a
drop-down and so on and so forth but it
is binary formatted serialized data and
there are classes in the.net framework
that you'd never be serializable which
is kind of gray and viewstate is
implicitly trusted so when view state
comes back again the view state class
will go okay I'm gonna deserialize these
and take a look at them because it can't
look at them and it's serialized it so
done that has this class called temp
file collection which is incredibly
useful I have to admit you spin one of
these collections up and you say give me
a new temp file name and it goes away
and it looks and it says yes here is a
unique filename that you can use and
when the temp file collection class is
disposed it cleans up after itself it
goes through that list of file names and
deletes them but you can add file names
to that collection file names like web
config and then your web config gets
deleted your SharePoint site goes down
and probably your users are happy
because they don't have to use
SharePoint anymore so let's take a
little look at this one no that one not
that one this one so what I'm going to
do in this one is I'm gonna create a web
config file and we'll swap over to
explore to see it and I can create an
attack file name and I'm gonna create
this temp file collection I'm gonna put
web config in it and then use binary
formatter to serialize and then I'm
going to pretend to be web config I'm
going to read this back in as if it was
viewstate deserialize it which is all we
view state is going today
and then I'm gonna force garbage
collection because frankly we don't want
to wait for this and the forcing of
garbage collection will mean that that
uptime file collection is going to be
disposed and lo and behold everything
will get deleted so but it really demos
few state okay so there's no web config
in here right now I'm gonna run this
okay so I've created a web.com Pig I'll
look Vera is there's nothing in it and
so I'm hitting enter this is reading my
views - its forced garbage collection my
garbage collection is done if I go back
here I have nowhere web.config in
SharePoint it's done which personally I
think is a good thing but never mind
sharepoint people give me so much
heartache an exchange did this recently
this came this was last month i'm yeah
this was last month so this one is new
for this every time I give this
presentation I go through the last three
months vulnerability sink oh yeah that
one looks fun exchange took this
slightly more seriously you see deleting
files is amusing hello every for full
remote code execution what you want to
do is you want to get to the point where
you can run arbitrary commands on the
server that you are sending stuff to and
we can do this with binary formatter
exchange web servers had an
authenticated endpoint so you had to
have an exchange username and password
for this all in the exchange server that
you were trying to attack so it's not so
bad but it's a nice demonstration an
accepted voicemail for transcription if
any of you have ever seen the transcript
it outputs from Skype for business
voicemail you'd think that this thing
just generates random data but
apparently it doesn't and the voicemail
is binary data formatted with binary for
matter so this is the demo that I don't
share I have here serialization exploit
set a startup project so it's going to
do much the same thing as we did before
it's going to take a payload it's going
to deserialize it through binary format
and we're gonna see some bad things so
if I start this
I'm gonna hit enter when I'm ready to go
and PowerShell is pop top that that
that's interesting and you know once I
have PowerShell well it's now
downloading stuff from the internet
which is quite scary and it's executed
the most horrific thing I can think of
for Australia which is taking the
winning ashes but that could be
something excuse me
something slightly less horrific like
you know stealing all your credit card
data kind of a problem I love that
pictures I got booed last year when that
came up even darker had this problem
docker fix this three weeks ago the duck
when the docker systems no call sister
said the docker notification area
application sends commands to the docker
service via named pipes and they have
forgotten set and access control on the
name pipes so anyone could access them
as long as they were on that machine and
their commands were encapsulated in
binary format err and the docker server
runs a system on a machine so you could
as a low privileged user start executing
commands as system on a server that you
were logged onto the docker on it which
is kind of problematic so if there are a
bunch of ways to fix this if you are run
tripping state to user control space you
need to grip grip so cryptographically
sign the data so you can detect that it
has not come from you you don't publish
your signing key on github which you
know if a lot of people do it's going to
get hub search for web config and search
for machine key stuff and you will cry
wee through machine key away and darknet
core and replace it with something
that's slightly safer and you don't use
any serialization format that allows an
attacker to specify the object type to
be serialized that's what
this whole thing boils down to binary
Fortner by earning formatter and all of
these things below all allow serialized
data to say hey I'm of type X and if you
can control what type X is you can get
remote code execution so you should
avoid binary format or fast Jason sweet
Oh Jason Jason done that if you set type
name handling to anything other than
none
the default is none done this JavaScript
serializer without having a type
resolver because the type resolver then
constrains stuff and some of you will be
using binary format or I am NOT gonna
ask anyone to raise hands for this and
you ago I cannot change my stuff because
I I require backwards compatibility now
I know all about having to keep crap
code for backwards compatibility believe
me but backwards compatibility should
not be a suicide pact at some point you
have to abandon it and move on to
something that's more secure if you are
stuck with binary format or you can try
this it's not as secure as switching to
a type Limited serializer but it gets
you three-quarters of the way there this
can still have problems depending on the
size of your classes it may run out of
memory but frankly a crash an art of
memory exception is far better than
remote code execution we make no
guarantees about this move your format
but if you're stuck in binary format or
this might be a reasonable stopgap for
you so if you take away one thing today
it's go and look for instances of binary
formatter in your code and remove them
regular expressions
I loathe and despise regular expressions
because they are incredibly hard to read
and also there are a language within
them
backtracking regular expressions can
move backwards and forwards through the
thing that they are trying to evaluate
and perform loops and all sorts of other
things it is possible to get
backtracking regular expressions into an
infinite loop and the way you fix that
is by putting a timeout on your regular
expressions unfortunately Dalton net
does not put a timer and regular
expression parsing by default and I
can't change it because
backwards-compatibility so we fixed this
sort of thing by adding time i'ts
everywhere how many of you using regular
expressions for data validation many of
those regular expressions are
backtracking how many you don't know
whether they're backtracking or not
thank you for your honesty so and done
that four point six loads of people were
like hey we want more data validators
because we don't want to write our own
validation ourselves when someone came
up with the bright idea of providing
some data validators for things like
email addresses using some open source
regular expressions funnily enough from
jQuery one of these is to validate an
email address this regular expression
does no exist anymore in any of our code
paths now personally I think you can
only validate an email address by
sending an email to it because just
checking the format is not enough so
here we're gonna run a regular
expression against a good value and then
we're gonna put in or we're gonna run a
good value against the regular
expression then we're gonna put in a bad
value and we're gonna run it against the
email regular expression which is this
for those of you that are using regular
expressions to validate stuff could
someone explain to me what this does can
you tell seriously can you tell by
reading this this is why I hate regular
expressions this is insane and it's
wrong because there's an awful lot more
to email addresses than the jQuery
regular expression or even the regular
expression in the RFC for email address
this can go twice so if I run this test
against a good value result is true
testing against the value and that's
gonna take an awfully long time to
finish and while it processes CPU usage
is gonna go tick tick tick tick tick
tick tick and you can denial service a
server with this it will finish
eventually it doesn't quite get itself
into an infinite loop but it takes act
an exponential amount of time to parse
so we'll close that off so we can fix
this by abandoning regular expressions
all together for the love of God they're
awful there was checking they're
checking an email address the right way
to do it is send an email you know
there's something on one side of an @
sign there's something on the other side
of an @ sign it might be in the email
address let's find ayat
that's a you follow their email
addresses you set timeouts and all your
regular expressions there is a timeout
value in don't let there's a time I
value in Ruby there's a timeout value in
Java go through all your regular
expressions to make sure they have time
lights and then if you realize that none
of your regular expressions of time
lights and you have like a couple of
hundred of them and you don't want to
set individual too much which is the
correct thing to do you can kind of
cheat for dollar framework you can set
that value which is a global time I for
all regular expressions which do not
have time eyes this does not exist in
dark net core and on that core go review
all your code input I might say manually
you don't need to take Piggy's if you go
to my website all of this will be
uploaded this afternoon so you can grab
everything from there cross-site
scripting in asp.net core I don't like
asp.net core vulnerabilities they are
painful for you guys to patch how many
of you are using dotnet and a speed on
that core how many of you understand how
we deliver patches
how many of you think patches will come
over Microsoft Update some of you are
lying because no one put their hands up
um we do not deliver dotnet core patches
over Microsoft Update mainly because
that doesn't work on 1x and we made a
promise that we would not force patches
down on you so we wouldn't break your
code and you can have your code running
against multiple versions of.net core
runtime at the same time so you can
isolate and move things one by one so
you have to manually update by
installing new SDKs installing new
runtimes and pulling down new packages
from you get and republishing which
makes developers very happy it makes ops
people like we have to rely on our
developers to do the right thing so when
you choose done that core you are taking
that responsibility all and I want you
to be very clear about that monitor the
announcements repos for both dotnet core
and asp.net core and every patch to see
if there is something it will be posted
there because we can't post it anywhere
else because we don't deliver via
Microsoft Update so MVC encodes every
piece of output by default that's what
the little ass hang does except when you
tell it not to which is what HTML dot
raw does if you see HTML raw in your
code and you are doing a review of your
code that's something that needs to be
very carefully looked at now in this
case it was fine when I give the sample
code across to the developers to turn
into a template and in between the stuff
that I'd written and the stuff that they
wrote they changed the way some of it
works because I tend not to write
idiomatic code I don't write things in
an MVC way I don't write things in a
razor pages way because I'm old and I
started off with COBOL and Pascal I
write things in the way that makes sense
to me and I go for clarity rather than
making it look like everything else does
so we had a combination here of an over
binding attack and access s in the in
asp.net core 2.0 where we added support
for
multifactor off here we go we generated
the the keys and the QR code information
on a particular screen on the server
side this is the way I wrote it was it
would just get shoved into the view
model on every single request and that's
not
idiomatic enough so it changed where it
was posted it was bindable so when you
hit a refresh you got an action you got
an error it was read out of the post
data that came through rather than being
regenerated every single time which was
silly because that hash the the key
value was rendered via HTML raw because
otherwise I could end up with double URL
encoding and it was a little bit messy
in the QR code would not scan so what
pimping pin point did was he discovered
this and he likes to make me unhappy
because he's French
I had to write him a check for this we
have a bug buggy for dotnet core if you
think you have something as a security
vulnerability and Dalton that court
don't post on github seriously if you
post it on github
I can't give you money if you report it
via secure at Microsoft comm and it is a
vulnerability I can give you money so if
you find something that spikes your CPU
if you find something where connections
never get dropped and you're running out
of resources on on your web server and
you think it is due to a bug in asp.net
core and not your own code it is
probably your own code but if you think
it's a problem in our code email secure
at Microsoft comm please don't create
github issues because they have to be
reported to us privately before the
lawyers will let me write checks and I
am generous with my checks because I
have a budget don't get that money every
year frankly I'd like to spend all the
budget so there's there's a the bug
Barney terms are on Microsoft comm they
will give you an idea of exactly how big
the checks are I can write
and if you give us a good repo then the
check sacks goes up we even extended it
but three months ago we had someone
report a bunch of things with docks and
docks were not covered and I'm like I
really want to give this guy check so I
had to go to the lawyers and say I would
like to change our terms and conditions
so we'll cover a speed up Nick Dalton
that coronae SP don't had court Docs
okay anyway and I'd like it black back
dated and I'm like they're like oh that
took a little bit to sort out but the
guy got his check it made me happy so
here we have an over binding volume
model arias let's just type in some
nozzles I submit query and it just comes
back again if I put the version in well
the oops version no sans things you do
it oh it's an edge and edge has a bunch
of nonsense that stops this there we go
okay so the oops version shove things up
in the query string and the way done
their core binding works despite my
efforts to stop this because back
compatibility and developers don't wanna
think about it is it will try and buying
stuff from first of all the form fields
then it will go up to the query string
and it used to go to response or request
headers but we don't do that anymore so
we could get an XSS fly here and I'm not
going to tell you why axis s is bad
because I'm sure you've all seen choice
talks and I really don't need to go
through that again but yes there we had
XSS from a security feature that I added
and was then mangled so don't use HTML
raw go through all your code and look
for it and then really carefully look at
where things are going from and things
that never should come from user input
you limit the binding by putting bind
never on your view model class and if
something is generated server-side
always generate a server site don't put
an interview model class and start
putting a hidden field which is what the
few model is to transport it between
requests
and then we had CSRF cross-site request
forgery so where I can send a request
from one site to another site and have
something happen we have ways to protect
against this there is a cross-site
request forgery token that is embedded
in every single form the NVC generates
and when you submit that form that token
is checked against a cookie value that
is on the user's machine so when an
attacker reads a form he gets value 1
for the CSRF token and a user gets value
2 so if he tricks the user it's the
wrong value and nothing matches up and
so for when you were resetting your
two-factor office a form originally and
someone decided the form was not
idiomatic enough because state was not
changing so they turned it into a get
request accept state was changing it was
regenerating these things and so if you
said I get requests to this thing that
reset your two-factor recovery codes
because it's a get request
there's no CSRF token so I don't get
requests and it reset the recovery codes
which doesn't do anything bad until
you've managed to lock yourself out if
you're a kind and want to use one of
your recovery codes and they've been
reset so for things that changed it just
make sure that you're using a post and
don't let people optimize security code
for the.net core templates who don't
realize the implications of this stuff
so soap how many of you have used soap
services so you all remember what wisdom
is it's what you've reinvented for Jason
with swagger oh we're gonna go to Jason
it's so much cleaner we're not gonna
make the same mistakes that we did
before oh yes you are
so we still it's metadata like swagger
and you point a client thing at it and
it generates a bunch of code that then
gets compiled and loaded so you don't
have to think about writing a client
yourself don't have framework has a
wisdom parser built into it which I did
know
bye until last year innate wisdom parser
takes wisdom generates the proxy object
and then loads it end process no one can
remember why that classes in there no
one uses it Visual Studio doesn't use it
has its own wisdom parser and so there
was a bug inside it because a bug inside
is about a URL Oh in the notes for all
these powerpoints it has links to the
researchers and the research that they
did if you want to read a little bit
more and so this in angel a particular
nation-state to target Russian speakers
in the Ukraine to compile code against
their machine because word had this soap
functionality that used darknets wisdom
parser they should never have been there
in the first place but I ever prompting
the user what was going on so you have a
word doc that has this payload they load
it up it calls out to dotnet it compiles
some code it loads it and it runs it
uh-huh so that has been disabled in
office now um but the only way you can
really fix this is don't be Ukrainian
and don't piss off Russia these you know
this was an Eau de we did not know about
this it got reported to us when it was
underneath active attack which is always
a joy from a security responders point
of view but it was seriously interesting
effects and don't write code that
generates code from user input compiles
it and runs it which is also swagger and
finally the mistrusting of user input so
this one was really nice I was I was so
impressed by this and this again is from
this year so URL helper and every seed
contains a bunch of methods for
generating URLs which includes absolute
URLs so it has the host name and the
protocol value in there and that host
name comes from the host header or
request because we have nowhere else to
get it from and the host header and a
request can be
controlled by an attacker no normally
that's not so bad because all you do is
you get rendered stuff back again you
get a bunch of HTML back again and you
are attacking yourself except for this
one thing in the MVC templates where you
send Password Reset emails and so the
password reset emails go out to a user
and so what Mikael did was he sent he
sent a request with the host header
pointing to a sample site under his
control and he sent request to the
password reset page and so the email
that was generated in the password reset
page used the demand for that he has
underneath his control and the email
goes out and it's been sent out by your
website it's been sent out by an IP
address our mail server that you control
so it looks completely valid the only
thing that's different is that the URL
that someone is going to go to to reset
their password is under the attackers
control and they can sit there and they
can intercept the password reset token
and then take over your account and even
bear there are certain email clients
that would render the HTML in this in
emails so depending on how you do this
things will get rendered and we'll send
get requests and you can do all sorts of
interesting CSRF stuff about stealing
tokens and stealing recovery tokens just
because you are using an email client
that renders HTML by default including
image tags like the one on your iPhone
so the way you fix this is you look at
your hosting and instead of being Lizzie
you don't listen for any host header you
don't configure your web servers to be
any Hostetter you limit them to the
house headers that you want to listen on
so you listen to you know WWE total calm
and contoso calm only
or you do a wild card because some
people do their multi-tenancy based on
URLs but you don't look at it with the
star and you validate all your inputs
according to the HTTP back because the
other nice thing he found was we were
not validating our host header because
we didn't really use it anywhere so you
could embed HTML in the host header that
ended up in the email so what I
demonstrated before with the timing
article is basically this there is an M
SRC advisory
it's that timely article where we don't
care about results or statuses and you
can't fix it so you don't really expose
these things again and you need to go
back to adding authenticated signatures
to encrypted data there is a huge
document about this for all of you that
are doing encryption in your systems I
strongly encourage you to read this and
start thinking about what you're seeing
so we have ten minutes let's go through
the silly things I've seen this before
where people are okay I have you know an
MVC encodes everything for me I'm gonna
do HTML and code on a title that's in a
tooltip the problem here is that it's in
JavaScript and the encoding for
JavaScript is entirely different to the
encoding for HTML and once you can't get
it right by getting it in the right
order if you get it in the wrong order
your screws so if you are passing things
in a page and you want to pull them out
in your JavaScript a better way to do it
is stick them in a div with the data tag
and pull it out of the data tag because
in the Davis just HTML encoded I'm gonna
do that for you and when your JavaScript
pulls the I it's using the right
encoding when it accesses it
culture languages are fun this will
print true or false depending on what
part of the world you are in now I know
Ozzy's have a problem with culture yeah
it's like that's what you pass off
Vegemite is cultured I've been trying to
get junk all the way to eat Vegemite all
week and apparently that shit-eating
grin I have when I try and serve it to
him just puts him off and I can't think
why
but tweet it you know tweet that's John
Galloway John without an inch and say
eat your veggie might and I'm sure he'll
do it alright cultures duh so many
vulnerability demos globalization there
we go
bless you sir or ma'am I can't see
I love trackpads until I like try and
have to click something so here we go
this is just going to do the culture
comparison and the first time it's true
and the second time the exact same code
is false because I've switched to
Turkish and in the Turkish language
there are multiple ways to represent a
capital I so that's problematic because
people do this on usernames and then you
make comparisons based on user names to
make security decisions so when you are
doing string comparisons strings are
compared always choose string comparison
to ordinal ignore kiss
there is a code analysis or a style call
rule for this there's even a roast
analyzer but I know none of you turn
these things on because they're noisy
turn that what about it's not just
turkey though an interesting thing that
we find when we were doing some Linux
stuff if you are in utf-8 in Thailand
starts with full stop crashes all Mac
and Linux because there are no
punctuation marks in the entire language
it works on Windows because windows
swallows the exception and just says no
it doesn't start with this Mac and Linux
it did not it's a really really
interesting I spent a lot of time
writing HTML encoders so I know I've
spent a lot of time going through the
Unicode specs but you can see it there
and it just describes how incredibly
bizarre some of these things are yeah it
doesn't even have zero width space so
this one this one is kind of I this one
caused a huge argument and work because
it's all net was being blamed for it
when really it was the MS IT person that
had written a really silly system and it
was like a week and a half of arguments
until I could prove them wrong and I
always like proving people wrong because
in my head I am 100% right 100% of the
time that's my wife will attest
so Unicode has this concept to fill with
characters and I know it's a little bit
hard to see you have the less than on
the left and the full-width or the
American version because I put on a
couple of stone when I moved becomes a
full-width version and it is in fact two
Unicode characters and there's a lot of
them so you can see that there's like
full wit for most of the alphabet and a
bunch of punctuation marks and browsers
know the difference they know that this
script tag is not an actual script tag
it's it's full with characters and what
this guy had done was he was like okay
we are we're doing like HTML and coding
we're doing a bunch of stuff and I'm
going to strip it I and then I'm gonna
persist everything into sequel and when
you put Unicode & Seek well you put it
into and varchar' right this guy did not
he put it into varchar' and sequel was
really helpful sequel one hey you have
full with characters now I don't want
you to lose data so what I'm gonna do is
I'm gonna take those full width
characters which are unicode and you're
sticking of our chart fields and i'm
gonna convert them to their normal width
characters so this script tag bypass all
of his filtering and then as soon as he
started in sequel it became a normal
script tag and he had persisted XSS so
you don't obviously start Unicode in a
non Unicode feel for this because
otherwise you wanna look at and you
don't don't filter don't try and fix
problems on data don't try and use
regular expressions as the famous
stackoverflow question has to parse
equal ordinates not in sequel HTML you
are doomed to failure with this the only
way to safely accept rich text really is
to these days is to use a markdown
parser and telemark darm parser not to
parse embedded HTML never trust anything
that comes from your database because
your database could be vulnerable your
database could have been compromised you
may have an idiot write in your database
schema so you should treat everything
coming from your database as hostile in
the same way that you would treat any
user input
any untrusted input and just HTML
encoder on the way crypto is fun
as you've seen I've seen this I've seen
that more practically people reuse their
encryption keys and their initialization
vectors too much when a document or
resource whatever you're trying to
encrypt changes change your key or if
you can't change your key definitely
change your initialization vector in
case of purposes so you shouldn't be
using the same key that you are using to
encrypt credit card transactions with to
encrypt email addresses with have
different keys for these things what you
can do if you only ever want to store
one key is you have a master key and
then you use key derivation functions
which take a purpose and do a bunch of
fun math with it and then generate new
keys from your master key that's what we
end up doing in the data protection
layer and like I said encrypted data it
needs to have your authenticated
signature on the end of it before you
try and do any decryption no another fun
one I've seen is people like do a bunch
of hashing stuff and they combine a
bunch of data together and so if you do
it without lengths it doesn't really
work because built in securely is the
same as built in securely when you can
count in it so if you are hashing
multiple values stick the lengths of
those values in there before you do the
hash path transversal when we're
uploading stuff always use unique names
don't trust what has come from the
browser then there's zip slip as well
which is reasonably new when you are
things the zip format allows paths and
file names the done that API generally
when you say unzip gets it right but it
also allows you to get file names and we
tell you what has come from the zip file
so it may include paths so you need to
just figure out whether it's included in
a path or not and can can hear that I
anyone that's accepting Zepps we aware
of things like zip bombs because a 42k
file can unzip into four point five
petabytes which is always fun
you did this one's really available in
the internet but you have to turn off
your virus scanner to download it and
send it to someone do that in your test
servers please don't do in your life
production data XML is exactly the same
thing you can prevent that by turning it
off DTD parsing
so in summary sign your data every
single piece of data that you have
should have a cryptographic signature on
it whether it's encrypted or whether
it's wrong tripped sign it and check the
check the signature first don't use
regular expressions the love of God
don't use binary format or any of those
other for matters that I pointed I don't
set up over binding an MVC excludes
things that aren't meant to be bind from
your view model oh he's usually right
HTTP verb don't give it don't give your
templates to other people to turn into
templates for the bundle in the visual
studio and validate your inputs and that
includes all your hosts headers so never
have your web server just listening for
star as a host header start limiting
these things we are out of time does
anyone have any questions I think I can
take one or two or are we all just too
scared or we don't want to admit things
all right I think we're we're probably
just all too scared don't want to omit
things are like screw you by Ray I want
another coffee it's 10:00 a.m. thank you
very much for coming have a good day
[Applause]